the Joe Rogan experience what do you got
Jamie what's up this is still I've got
the last one but right most famous one
they were at 230 degrees Fahrenheit
which was 110 Celsius oh and at 6
minutes the I think the guy on the left
in this picture passed out and ended up
dying no he died yeah I cook my steak at
110 Celsius Jesus holy [ __ ] it's
incredible huh oh oh my god
Russian competitor dies in sauna world
championship yeah [ __ ] that how long
were they in there six minutes or so I
think what it says lasts for six minutes
and they took them out oh so it's a
temperature sixty-year-old over 60 oh my
God look how ready is Nicholas I cook my
steak at 110 no joke this is Annie in
here 110 Celsius is what Fahrenheit 230
2/3 very dangerous yeah I was doing 220
you know he had me doing 220 for a
little bit but you know what I feel like
it was burning my lungs
I feel like I was burning the inside of
my mouth was dry yeah I felt terrible I
stopped doing it I did a few times but
afterwards I'd lay down after I did it
and I was doing it for [ __ ] like 15
20 minutes - what was the purpose mark
me I was just her I wanted to experiment
but what what does he do it I don't he
dude first of all he's built different
mmm this guy has an ankle that's like
three of these Yeti cooler mugs because
he broke it and just kept working out on
and after he broke it so it's all
calcified he pulled it up put it up on
the table it's like what the [ __ ] man he
just broke his ankle and just kept
working out and kept doing stuff on it
and then it just sort of fused together
and this like look at his ankle ooh look
at that oh my god that's his ankle man
that's just from breaking and never
stopping to do anything with it yeah
it's like it's like the root of a tree
it's real weird man he's a crazy person
but he's also you know like one of the
greatest surfers that ever lived and I
think sometimes you have to be that -
boy that they're all crazy yeah
everybody's that the best of their game
they're all crazy they're all crazy
I always matter what you do they're all
they're all they're all this is a touch
of genius and there's a touch of madness
I see that man
and genius or next-door neighbors and
they borrow each other sugar neighbors
you you have to be like literally
[ __ ] up almost every other part of
your life to achieve real greatness yeah
because you got a abandon personal
relationships you got to be totally
unbalanced you completely obsessed and
focused upon your goal this is true but
the beautiful thing for a fighter is
fighters can do that in camp and then
break and then take a little break so
much don't not too much okay it's not
too much space how much time do you like
after a fighter like Kevin wins how much
time do you recommend to just [ __ ] off I
think two weeks is good two weeks of
[ __ ] off yeah just go chill for two
weeks but I feel like everybody wants to
take a month and six weeks I think
that's too much there's too much to
learn Mme
there's too much right you know you know
one position that can win you the fight
so in that six weeks how many positions
did you did you miss out on that you
don't know about there's so many
positions there's so many scenarios to
go over yeah there's too much material
to cover
[Applause]